بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله واشهد ان لا اله
الا الله واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين اما بعد
يقول الله تعالى
في الايه الثامنه من سوره المزمل
السوره الثالثه
من كتاب الله تعالى واذكر اسم ربك
وتبتل اليه تبتيلا
سبحانه وتعالى ان منشن
‏name
ربك
name
‏If we were to look at this verse
without the context of the rest of the
chapter on its own
just to plck it out on its own and look
at it isolated from other verses
it would mean remember the name of your
lord
and most obvious meaning meaning that a
person makes
‏name
are
however if
we look
واذكر واذكر
here means
‏nameران
[Silence]
ورتل القران ترتيلا الله سبحانه وتعالى
ر
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
بسم الله
الله
فقوله واذكر اسم ربك
اذا كان وحده هكذا
تفهم الايه
على مطلق ذكر اسم الله سبحانه وتعالى
وماه
من تسبيح او تكبير او تحميد وهو كغيره من
اوامر الله سبحانه وتعالى بالذكر وذكر
اسمه سبحانه
واذا كان في من حيث الايه في السوره وفي
موضع السوره والواو كانت عاطفه فهي عاطف
معطوفه على او الجمله معطوفه على قوله
تعالى قم الليل
قم الليل ورتل القران ترتيلا واذكر اسم
ربك
وتبتل اليه تبتيلا اي قل بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم كما علمك الله
say بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
this way and two opinions
both of
‏any a
has multiple multiple multiple that the
ver could be underst under as long as
these meanings are not in conflict with
each other then the verse means all of
them right there is no problem with
that that a statement is
‏Schlic
means all of those potential meanings.
‏And we don't have one time have
and another
is because those are inli
now why is that
because Allah
could very well have stated whatever
that meaning is in absolute terms and
leave no room
‏or third
delberately chose
words that could mean a multitude of
things why did he choose to use
ambiguous
set of words in order for the verse
to carry more than just one meaning that
is the way that it is made on purpose
that is by design of course and
الله سبحانه وتعالى
واذكر اسم ربك
name
before
you بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
وتبتل
اليه تبتيلا
وتبتل اليه تبتيلا
بتل البتل في اللغه القطع
البا
وال
مثل البتل والبتر
والبت
يعني بات ت البت والبتل والبتر كل هذه
تحمل معاني ايش القطع
والتفرقه بين
الشيء
من نفسه
بتل
الله سبحانه وتعالى
الى
وتبتل اليه يعني الى ربك
تبتيلا
الله سبحانه وتعالى
وتبتل اليه
تحمل معنى الانتهاء
يعني في اللغه الى لها معاني كثيره
لكن لو قلت مثلا
ذهبت الى المسجد ذهبت الى المسجد ايش معنى
الى هنا الى بمعنى الانتهاء يعني ذهبت حتى
انتهيت
في المسجد
فقوله وتبتل اليه تبتيلا يعني اقطع نفسك
عن التعلق بجميع ما سوى الله وتعلق اليه
وحده سبحانه وتعالى
الله
سبحانه وى
‏is
with to
att
someone
our
way to
everything else is
‏only that we are
hanging our hearts upon and
the only ones that the only one that we
areelying upon the only one that we are
place all of our hes all of our dreams
all of our fears
in that
سبحانه وتعالى الله
وتبتل اليه تبتي التبتل
التبتل
المتبتل
قريش
mind
وتبتل اليه تبتيally
[Silence]
متلت
المتبت
وتبتل اليه
الله سبحانه وتالى
have
ان شاء الله
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوفقنا جميعا
ستع القول واتباع
احسنه نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يوفقنا لاخذ
الكتاب بقوه نساله سبحانه وتعالى ان يغفر
لنا وان يغفر وان يرحمنا وان يتوب علينا
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا محمد